donc Mesdames Messieurs les chers
collègues nous lançons aujourd'hui
l'étude de la délégation
sénatorial de l'outremè sur l'adaptation
des modes d'action de l'État dans les
outremers Philippe Bas sénateur de la
Manche et Victorin Lurel sénateur de
Guadeloupe ont bien voulu en être les
rapporteurs et je vous en
remerci pour notre première audition
nous avons convié les auteurs de la
dernière étude annuelle du Conseil
d'État au titre explicite l'usager au du
1er au dernier kilomère de l'action
publique un enjeu d'efficacité et une
exigence démographique ces auteurs ont
bien voulu répondre à notre invitation
et je vous en remercie infiniment madame
la présidente de la section du rapport
et des études madame Martine
boadefre monsieur le président adjoint
et rapporteur général de cette section
monsieur Fabien R et la rapporteur
générale adjointe madame Mélanie Villier
donc je vais vous laisser la parole
madame la Présidente pour un propos
introductif que vous m'avez annoncé un
peu long mais nous sommes à votre écoute
et nous poursuivrons par l'intervention
des rapporteurs et puis des questions
dans dans la salle merci à vous madame
la Présidente messieurs les rapporteurs
Mesdames et Messieurs les les membres de
la délé tion je voudrais tout d'abord en
notre nom à tous les trois vous
remercier de nous avoir invité à
intervenir aujourd'hui dans le cadre
donc de l'étude de la délégation sur
adaptation des modes d'action de l'État
dans
l'outrem je vous remercie d'autant plus
vivement que j'apprends que nous ouvrons
si j'ose dire les les auditions donc
l'honneur on est redoublé je vous
remercie aussi de l'intérêt que vous
portez à l'étude annuelle donc du
Conseil d'État de 2023 dont vous avait
rappelé le le titre nous accordons en
effet beaucoup d'importance aux
relations entretenues avec le Sénat et
j'espère que le changement que nous
avons introduit dans la façon dont nous
sommes assis n'a pas été considéré comme
une tentative de prise de pouvoir ou un
empiettement sur votre indépendance mais
au contraire comme le souhait de pouvoir
nous adresser à l'ensemble des
sénatrices et sénateurs présents les
rencontres entre les parlementaires et
les membres du Conseil d'État sont en
effet à nos yeux essentiels pour assurer
la compréhension et plus largement la
confiance entre nos
institutions je suis donc accompagné de
Fabien Renault président adjoint de la
section du rapport et des études
rapporteur général de l'étude 2023 et de
Mélanie Villier rapporteur général
adjoint de cette étude il se tiennent
comme VO à votre disposition vous nous
avez envoyé au préalable un
questionnaire et je voudrais dembler
préciser et cela ne vous étonnera pas
que nous sommes là pour exprimer la
position que le conseil d'État a adopté
dans le cadre de l'étude sur le dernier
kilomètre il nous sera donc impossible
de répondre à des question qu'il n'a pas
abordé et encore moins de vous faire
part de nos opinions personnelles sur
tel ou tel point nous ne sommes devant
vous que les porte-paroles du Conseil
d'État et de sa collégialité ce qui
n'est pas rien mais c'est cela
seulement vous connaissez nos études et
je n'y reviendrai pas sauf si vous aviez
des questions postérieurement vous avez
lu l'étude annuelle 2023 à raison de
laquelle vous avez souhaité nous
entendre mon propos consistera donc
madame la Présidente à répondre en fait
aux quatre premières questions qui nous
semblait euh d'une ampleur telle qu'elle
répondait aussi peut-être à la fois
l'état d'esprit dans lequel nous avions
travaillé et à la méthode que nous
avions suivi donc je vais aborder
successivement les quatre premières
questions tout d'abord comment décliner
outreem le renouvellement des modes de
conception de mise en œuvre et de
fonctionnement de l'État que l'étude
appelle de ses
vœux notre étude vous l'avez vu vous le
verrez à un champ très vaste car nous
avons décidé d'adopter une vision
transversale aux politiques publies au
service public à l'action publique en
général sur l'ensble du territoire
français et donc nous nous sommes
intéressés à
l'outreem quelques exemples nous avons
réalisé de nombreuses auditions et avons
entendu des acteurs du dernier kilomètre
outreem des élus d'outrem comme Stéphane
artanau sénateur de Saint-Pierre et mlon
maot broserson député de la Polynésie
française le préfet de la Réunion Jérôme
filopini et la sous-préfette chargée
dans la même île de la cohésion sociale
et de la jeunesse des directeurs
d'administration le directeur général de
la RS de Mayotte monsieur le
sénateur le également donc Olivier braic
le directeur de la DAL réunion Philippe
Gramont la secrétaire générale pour les
affaires régionales de la Réunion
Nathalie Infante se font également
auditionné les tribunaux administratif
d'outrem avec d'autres par l'envoi d'un
questionnaire nous avons adressé à tous
les tribunaux administratifs pour
essayer de mesurer quelle était
l'efficacité du dernier kilomètre de la
juridiction administrative mais nous
avons d'ailleurs auditionné également le
président du tribunal administratif de
la Réunion et de maotte en centrale nous
avons entendu le secrétaire général du
ministère de l'Intérieur et des autremes
la directrice de la Direction générale
des oututr-emes et un certain nombre de
ses
collaborateurs mais ce ce sur quoi je
dois insister c'est que une fois le
constat établi dans la première partie
de notre étude d'un fossé qui s'est
creusé entre l'action publique et les
usagers sur l'ensemble du territoire la
métropole et les outr-merses sans que
nous ayons fait un sort particulier aux
outremers de la même façon les
propositions que nous formulons dans la
seconde partie ont vocation à nos yeux à
s'appliquer tant en métropole coutreire
elle concerne l'état administration
centrale comme service déconcentrés mais
également
les autres acteurs du dernier kilomètre
comme les collectivités
territoriales pour répondre donc très
précisément à la première question
l'étude n'émet pas de recommandation
spécifique à l'outrem
elle préconise elle propose un
changement de méthode qui pour nous vaut
sur l'ensemble du territoire y compris
ultramarin pour combler le fossé que
nous constatons entre les usagers
l'action publique le Conseil d'État
formule 12 propositions toutes tirées
j'y insiste de bonnes pratiques que nous
avons recueillis lors des auditions et
observés sur le terrain je précise quand
même que nous ne sommes pas allés
outreem nous sommes allé sur le terrain
en métropole mais nous n'avons pas fait
de déplacement outreem l'enjeu donc pour
nous consiste à partir des bonnes
pratique constaté relevé mise en lumière
à changé de braquer ces 12 propos I
assume une ambition modeste modeste car
aucune n'est complètement originale mais
ambition car il nous semble que leur
mise en œuvre conjointe et complète
supposera un effort de tous les acteurs
et des usagers eux-mêmes ces 12
propositions visent à Renou avec une
culture du service en rendant les
acteurs et les usagers acteur de ce
changement elle s'articule autour de
trois axes essentiels pour assurer à nos
yeux la mise en œuvre du dernier
kilomètre de l'action publique un
impératif de proximité un besoin de
pragmatisme et un maîre mot la confiance
de notre étude il ressort et cela vaut
particulièrement là à notre avis pour
les territoires ultramarins il ressort
donc qu'il faut penser pardonnez-moi
cette expression un peu familière qu'il
faut penser à l'atterrissage de l'action
publique dès le départ et dans tous les
endroits où elle va se déployer il faut
donc se poser la question concrète de
comment atteint-on celui que nous avons
appelé l'usager de façon générique qui
peut être un bénéficiaire de politique
publique ou un usager de service public
et tout particulièrement je posé la
question dès le départ pour l'outre
maire pourquoi parce que les
parlementaires représentants les outrè
que nous avons auditionné nous a indiqué
à cet égard qu'il la revenait souvent
d'appeler l'attention du des
gouvernements c'est une façon un peu
générique que je vais utiliser pour
m'exprimer sur le fait qu'il fallait
penser aux outrem donc de même que nous
disons qu'il faut penser le premier
kilomètre dès le dernier kilomètre il
faut penser le premier kilomètre aux
outrem ou le premier kilomètre des
usagés de l'outrem d pardon il faut
penser le dernier kilomètre qui est
aussi le prier kilomè des usagers des
outrem
d le premier kilomètre de la conception
de la mise en œuvre d'une politique
publique d'un dispositif ou d'un
formulaire nous avons également constaté
puisque nous nous sommes intéressés à ce
qui s'était passé pendant le
covid qu'une chaîne courte a existé
entre le ministère de l'outremè et les
acteurs ultramarins qui a constitué sans
doute un atout pour la mise en œuvre du
dernier kilomètre de l'action publique à
ce moment très particulier en générant
davantage de fluidité peut-être des
allers-retours plus fréquent y compris
par rapport à ce qui pouvait se passer
en métropole alors je voudrais indiquer
simplement deux
exemples tirés donc des
auditions que nous avons retenu et qui
illustrent bien certains aspects de nos
propositions nous avons indiqué et il
s'agit des propositions 5 à 8 qu'il
importait de concevoir les politiques
publiques avec les usagers les acteurs
publics et à cette égard nous avons je
crois qu'il y a au moins deux personnes
venant de Guadeloupe ici nous avons
signalé le cas de l'école Louis Andrea
de bemmao en Guadeloupe où l'équipe
pédagogique a mis en place avec succès
depuis plusieurs années des moyens de
travail collectif entre enseignants pour
s'efforcer d'apporter des réponses à
s'adapé aux difficultés REP repéré parmi
les élèves donc voyez quelque chose
d'interactif un dispositif qui a été
reconnu par les services académiques
sous le nom d'idéas pour identifier
diagnostiquer s'engager accompagner et
être accompagné suivre
desjalons de la même façon à propos de
la proposition numéro 11 que nous
faisons qui va dans le sens d'une
logique de coopération et qui préconise
la logique des guichets uniques ou
intégrés au débat sur la gouvernance
nous avons relevé en NRE mer des
pratiques
intéressantes notamment dans les mairies
polynésiennes en Polynésie en effet le
député broserson nous a dit combien la
mairie est importante pour les usagers
elle est bien entendu aussi en métropole
et nous l'avons souvent dit et répété
dans toutes nos études et nous avons
souligner que la mairie est un des le
maire sont un des acteurs du essentiel
du dernier kilomètre aux yeux d'ailleurs
de nos concitoyens mais en Polynésie la
mairie est aussi un lieu de vie pour les
Polynésiens on vient y prendre le café
se retrouver discuter et donc il a été
décidé d'amener les services publics là
où sont les personnes dans une logique
du allz
vert la mairie acteur majeur du kilomètr
regroupe ainsi différents services on
peut même dire qu'on y regroupe un peu
tout dans une logique de quichet intégré
au service dans la plus grande proximité
de
tous cela montre aussi l'importance du
rôle des élus locaux que nous signalons
de façon répétée depuis notre étude sur
la citoyenneté en 2018 ou dans celle sur
les états d'urgence de 2021
deè question avons-nous identifié de
vraies spécificités de l'action de
l'État dans les outr
m dans la même logique que la réponse à
la première question l'étude n'identifie
pas en tant que tel des spécificités de
l'action de l'État dans les outres mèes
et ce n'était pas notre objectif
elle s'attache à analyser je le répète
si telle ou telle action publique
atteint les destin qu'elle a elle-même
déterminé si oui grâce à quoi et si non
à cause de quoi nous avons donc
travaillé sans considération a priori du
territoire que l'action publique
concerne même si pour avoir une approche
territoriale fine nous sommes allés sur
le terrain maison métropole rencontrer
usagers et acteurs de proximité dans le
Nord en beniloire dans la Drome dans
l'éérau avec le concours des préfectures
et des sous-préfectures
nous avons également pris en compte les
spécificités parfois les fragilités de
certains territoires zones rurales
quartien urbain sensibl et nous sommes
intéressés au territoire ultramarin et
nous avons pu constater c'est donc dans
notre étude que l'État a pris des
initiatives depuis une dizaine d'années
pour lutter contre le sentiment de
relégation de certains territoire et je
pense notamment en ce qui concerne les
outr m à la loi de pr pramation relative
à l'égalité réelle outreem loi et Rome
de février 2017 qui a été adopté vous le
savez mieux que moi avec pour objectif
de réduire les écarts de niveau de vie
et de situation avec
l'Hexagone ces écarts et pardonnez-moi
j'enfonce devant vous une porte que vous
connaissez bien et une porte ouverte
sont en effet très importants c'est le
cas en terme de richesse par habitant
d'écart de prix avec la métropole de
taux de décrochage scolaire de deux fois
plus élevé qu'en métropole de taux de
chômage très supérieur à la moyenne
nationale et de taux de pauvreté une
personne sur 5 vit sous le seuil de
pauvreté aux antillillant en Guyane les
territoires les plus durement touchés
étant la Guyane et Maillotte de même
nous avons constaté que nous savons que
les conditions d'accès des ultramarins à
certains services essentiels sont
souvent
insuffisantes les plans de convergence
établis en application de la loi et Rome
sur 10 ou 20 ans se fixent pour objectif
de réduire ses écarts de développement à
horizon de 20 ou 30 ans tout en tenant
compte des spécificités des territoires
ultramarins l'État à par ailleurs et
nous nous en faisons
l'écho développer une logique là aussi
qu'une ou une démarche que nous
proposons de généraliser le halé vert
voit le allécher dans certains
territoires
d'outrem nous citons par exemple les
audiences foreaines de justice en
Polynésie française nous citons aussi
toujours pour le ministère de la Justice
la mise en place avec le ministère de
l'intérieur d'une pirogue du droit en
Guyane à laquelle participe avocat
juristes et magistrats administratif ou
judiciaire et des pirogues rattachés aux
sous-préfectures de Saint-Laurent du
Maroni et de Saint-Georges de
l'Oyapoc trè question relative aux
politiques publiqu les moins bien
déployé dans l'Hexagone et dans les
outremers et raison du
constat au terme de l'étude et c'est là
aussi un constat général que nous
portons force de constater que malgré
des progrès certains l'action publique
ne parvient pas dans un certain nombre
de cas à atteindre effectivement le
dernier kilomètre jusqu'au public
qu'elle vise jusqu'aux usagés au sens
générique du terme ce faux c'est nous
l'avons constaté sans phare ni
complaisance nous nous sommes efforcés
d'en rechercher les causes directes et
indirectes notamment dans les conditions
de mise en œuvre de l'action publique
encore trop souvent caractérisé par sa
verticalité par le poids des normes vous
savez que c'est une préoccupation que
nous avons en commun mais également par
la complexité qui trop souvent pèse sur
les
usagers vous pourrez à cet égard vous
portter au 26 an quart qui jalogne
l'étude et qui font pleinement saisir ce
qui fait une action publique plus ou
moins efficace quant à l'atteinte si
jeose dire des usagers qu'elle visent
nous avons donc pointer des réussites et
des échecs à partir toujours je tiens à
le dire d'exemples qui nous ont été
donnés dans les auditions dans nos
déplacements sur le
terrain donc les échecs je vais me
borner à les citer on y reviendra s'il
le faut pour les échecs si j'ose dire
qui sont un peu partout en revanche je
m'appuierai un peu plus et je
m'attarderai un peu plus sur ce qui est
plus spécifique à l'outreem certains
échecs donc sont si je vous dire un peu
partout le chèque énergie le chèque
énergie qui donc quand même un ce des
personnes qui ont droit n'y recourt pas
tout simplement parce que chaque énergie
ça donne l'impression que vous allez
avoir immédiatement un chèque qui est
pour vous alors qu'il s'agit en été de
payer le fournisseur d'électricité ou
d'énergie nous avons aussi des
dispositif qui font l'effet d'une boîte
noire ou d'une garee de triillage pour
les usagers nous avons pensé à parcours
sup
qui régulle l'enseignement supérieur
mais derrière il y a le problème de
toute façon des places accessibles et
des places existante nous avons égal mis
en également mis en évidence les
difficultés à remplir certains
formulaires et qui s'ils sont en plus
dématérialisés combinent non pas pour
tous nos concitoyens la
dématérialisation est un succès pour
beaucoup d'entre eux enfin quand même la
Défenseur des droits mettant en avant 13
millions de personnes atteintes par
l'électronisme pour quand même une assez
forte minorité d'entre eux rend très
difficile l'accès ou empêche l'accès à
certains dispositifs il en est d'autres
encore sur lesquels je ne reviendrai pas
mais passons peut-être a des exemples
plus spécifiquement tirés de l'outrem et
je le répète que nous avons entendu que
nous avons recueilli et auquel nous
avons souhaité donner un écho dans notre
étude la carte
vitale pour les étudiants venant de
Polynésie je ne vais rien vous apprendre
mais ça nous a quand même frappé et donc
je veux vous en parler les jeunes
quittont la Polynésie pour la métropole
afin d'y poursuivre leurs études descou
ouvre pardonnez-moi les joies entre
guillemets d'un nouveau système de
sécurité sociale la Polynésie est tant
au titre de son statut de collectivité
d'outremère autonome et compétente en la
matière obligation leur est alors fait
de cocher la case étranger de passage
sur le formulaire à remplir pour obtenir
une carte Vitale
cela nous a plonger dans la perplexité
et ce en dépit des nombreuses
interventions des élus et parlementaires
du territoire pour le faire
évoluer par ailleurs combien ne votent
pas faute d'avoir pu s'inscrire à temps
sur les listes électorales de leur
nouvelle commune de
résidence la rationalisation des
administrations territoriales que nous
avons
constaté sans en contester bien souvent
le bien fondé la légitimité
mais rencontre des limites nous avons
relevé par exemple excusez-moi je veux
encore parler de la Polynésie mais
l'exemple de la fermeture des maternités
incontestable pour des raisons de
sécurité mais qui a eu des effets
collatéraux en autre mer et tout
particulièrement donc en Polynésie en
effet alors qu'il était possible
autrefois d'accoucher dans les atols les
autorités sanitaires ont fait le choix
de regrouper et je le répète pour des
raisons tout à fait est légitime et
qu'on comprend bien que nous femmes en
particulier pardonnez-moi ce petit
développement nous comprenons donc pour
des raisons de sécurité l'on a regroupé
l'essentiel des accouchements à Tahiti
il en résulte de
conséquences forte et peut-être d'un
point de vue symbolique mais forte pour
les
Polynésiens d'abord les motifs
sanitaires affectent les coutumes du
territoire notamment cell consistant à a
planté un arbre sur le placinta de la
mer à la naissance d'un enfant et par
ailleurs tous les enfants sont désormais
enregistrés au registre d'état civil de
papééé dernier exemple le passeculture
le passeculture nous considérons que
globalement c'est un succès et parce que
non seulement il va vers les personnes
mais qu'il donne en quelque sorte un
pouvoir aux usagers parce que avec ce
Pass ils vont choisir telle ou telle
dimension de la culture mais nous
signalons que le niveau d'appropriation
du dispositif est encore très inégal
selon les territoires les jeunes des
villes activent davantage leur
passeculture que les jeunes du monde
rural en raison notamment d'un accès
plus difficile aux offres culturel les
résultats sont encore plus mitigés
outreem je dirais simplement que 4 % des
jeunes maorés utilise le passculture
contre 84 % à
Paris mais il y a aussi des
succès des succès sur l'ensemble du
territoire le prélèvement à la source
par exemple dont toutes les personnes
que nous avons rencontré que nous enons
parlé ont présenté comme un succès en ce
qui concerne les outrmères il y a des
succès aussi qu'il faut souligner et qui
ont inspiré ensuite nos propositions
d'abord les maisons France service les
maisons France service qui ont atteint
maintenant leur objectif qui était de
2500 labellisation il y a aujourd'hui 2
enfin 2022 2543 espace France service
était labellisé dont les 2 tiers dans
des communes rurales et 112 dans les
départements et régions d'outrem ainsi
qu'à Saint-Martin
99 % des Français sont ainsi à moins de
30 minutes d'une maison France service
et pardon 99 % des Français sont ainsi à
moins de 30 minutes d'une maison France
service et 90 % à moins de 20 minutes je
ne reviens pas sur les expériences que
et les succès que j'ai déjà mentionné de
l'allé vert tels que les mairies les
audiences foraines de justice en
Polynésie ou les pirogues en Guyane je
voudrais citer une
initiative locale à priori plus
étonnante il ne s'agit pas pour moi du
tout de contester le fait que le
français est la langue de la République
en fait la disposition constitutionnelle
mais le préfet de la Réunion que nous
avons auditionné
nous a indiqué qu'il n'a pas hésité à
communiquer en
créole sur les réseaux sociaux pendant
la crise sanitaire il s'agissait pour
lui d'être sûr d'être entendu par tous
et de la même façon que nous disons
justement que la proximité nous y
reviendrons dans les réponses aux autres
questions que la proximité c'est aussi
de parler aux gens et de parler de la
façon la plus adaptée et d'une façon
compréhensible et bien la là pour lui il
nous l'a expliqué il s'agissait donc
d'être entendu par les habitants de les
atteindre et finalement d'adapter
l'action publique et même la
communication publique en période de
circonstances
exceptionnelles la 4e question et je
vais donc terminer ce propos qui
j'espère n'est pas trop long pose la
question de savoir si une nouvelle
organisation déconcentré de l'État
serait une des clés de la réussite du
dernier kilomètre et quelle réforme
serait prioritaire outreemère
je crains de vous
décevoir en vous disant que nous avons
raisonné à organisation et à moyen
constant car nous avons considéré que
nous n'étions pas
légitimes pour préconiser une
organisation territoriale de la France
pour porter un jugement sur
l'organisation
actuelle nous nous borenons à constater
dans la première partie de notre étude
que les réformes de l'État la
rationalisation des administrations
territoriales à partir de 2010 ont
profondément changé le visage de l'État
sur le terrain les préfectures et
sous-préfectures ne sont plus le lieu de
contact de l'administration avec les
citoyens la direction générale des
finances public à profondément
restructurer son réseau et cetera nous
ne proposons donc pas pour autant de
réformer l'organisation déconcentrée de
l'État il ne nous appartient pas de le
faire il faut connaître ses limites ni
de porter un jugement sur telle ou telle
politique publique ou telle réforme de
l'État passer ou
avenir en
revanche ce que nous disons c'est qu'il
est
important de penser dès l'amont d'une
réforme aux moyens qui seront
nécessaires pour la mener à bien penser
selon une formule très encore plus
familière plus terre à terre si j'ose
dire que le dernier kilomètre penser
l'atterrissage d'une politique publique
d'un dispositif d'un formulaire comment
va-t-il atterrir donc quel moyen faut-il
moyen en personnel moyen budgétaire il
faut penser l'intendance dès le début et
ne pas se dire qu'elle suivra penser les
difficultés dès l'amont c'est du bon
sens mais il nous semble que s'il était
mise en œuvre dans une logique de plus
grande coopération de subsidiarité
cela produirait des améliorations
importantes or si l'on
améliore ce dernier kilomètre des
services publics des politiques
publiques de l'action publique il nous
semble que non seulement l'on est plus
efficace mais que l'on renforce la
confiance de nos concitoyens dans la
dite politique publique je voudrais
ensuite vous dire que nos propositions
sont un tout et un tout effectivement
qui s'appliquerait pour nous
à tous les territoires y compris
l'ultramarin en tenant compte après de
la nécessité point par point de faire du
surmesure ça nous ne le nions absolument
pas parce que les réponses sont en
fonction de telle ou telle situation la
méthode doit rester la mêmees mais les
réponses concrètes peuvent être
différentes ce n'est donc comme nous
avons coutume de le dire qu'une sorte de
discours de la méthode que nous tenons
mais nous considérons que si vraiment ce
que nous proposons été mise en œuvre
cela induirait un changement profond
cela permettrait de redonner la parole
aux agents aux acteurs publics de
terrain mais également aux usagers cela
supposerait qu'on leur fasse confiance
et c'est le maître
mot je ne peux donc pas vous dire quelle
réforme serait prioritaire en NRE m nous
proposons plutôt de mettre en œuvre
ensemble les propositions formulées et
surtout de penser
l'outrem dès le début et de penser le
dernier kilomître dans les outremes dès
le 1emier kilomètre de la conception
d'une politique publique de la réflexion
sur un dispositif ou même de
l'élaboration d'un formulaire je vous ai
donné tout à l'heure un exemple un peu
surprenant merci infiniment madame la
Présidente merci mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les les sénateurs et tout
particulièrement messieurs les
rapporteurs et pardonnez-moi d'avoir été
un peu long mais j'ai traité ainsi je
l'espère cela ne n empêchera pas de nous
poser évidemment d'autres questions les
les quatre premières questions que vous
nous aviez
posé merci madame la Présidente pour ce
propos liminire qui était très très très
riche je vais sans plus attendre laisser
la parole
à au ministre Philippe B qui et puis
après notre deuxème rapporteur
victorel
merci madame la Présidente et merci
madame la Présidente de votre
exposé euh très
éclairant ce serait intéressant que le
Conseil d'État un jour mais nous ne
prétendons pas infléchir votre programme
euh se penche
spécifiquement sur le champ des
adaptations
possibles de la législation au aux
exigences de l'action de l'État
outreemre le Conseil d'État nous a déjà
bien aidé dans les années récentes et
j'ai un exemple qui me vient à l'esprit
malheureusement notre collègue t Mohamed
soli n'est pas là pour en témoigner
c'est l'examen que le Conseil d'État a
fait de la proposition de loi qu'il
avait déposé pour adapter le code de la
nationalité aux spécificités
de la situation à
Mayotte c'était très intéressant parce
que nous doutions les uns et les autres
et les auteurs de la proposition de loi
les premiers de la
possibilité de mettre sur le compte des
adaptations prévues par l'article 73 de
la
Constitution les
entorse au au droit du
sol que
la proposition de loi voulait faire et
vous avez trouvé avec les auteurs de la
proposition de loi une solution ce qui
prouve d'ailleurs que cette
collaboration
entre le Parlement et le Conseil d'État
sur les propositions de loi peut-être
très féconde il nous arrive de
sous-estimer l'ampleur des possibilités
d'adaptation que la
Constitution nous permet
d'explorer et c'est dommage il est vrai
qu'il y a aussi une jurisprudence du
Conseil constitutionnel et qu'on ne peut
pas faire n'importe
quoi mais nous rencontrons et nos
collègues élu d'outremire les
connaissent bien beaucoup d'obstacles à
l'efficacité de l'action de l'État
d'ordre
juridique moi je ne suis pas du tout un
spécialiste de ces obstacles mais j'ai
eu l'occasion par
exemple et notre collègue patient pourra
je parle sous son contrôle et avec
prudence me démentir je me souviens d'un
déplacement de la commission des lois en
Guyane qui était très instructif je vous
cite des
anecdote une institutrice dans la forêt
amazonienne prépare au baccalauréat un
élève qui n'a pas pu se rendre à Cayenne
pour poursuivre ses études elle est
sanctionnée elle n'a pas les
qualifications nécessaire son élève a
obtenu le baccalauréat mais elle elle
n'aurait pas dû le préparer alors on se
dit bah tiens peut-être qu'on pourrait
adapter euh parce que c'était une œuvre
utile et même une bonne action qu'on
pourrait adapter nos règles je je prends
un exemple très simple parce que de même
que votre exemple sur la carte vital
était très parlant celui-là me paraît
éloquant nous avons en Guyane aussi dans
la forêt amazonienne euh des orpailleurs
souvent brésiliens ils arrivent avec de
véritables commandau armée des bases vie
et euh c'est parfois l'armée française
qui intervient mais si on veut les
poursuivre pour les délits qu'ils ont
commis il nous faut des officiers de
police judiciaire ça n'est pas du tout
le genre de formation qu'on donne à nos
militaires évidemment comment faire pour
adapter la procédure pénale euh aux
exigences de la lutte contre les
orpailleurs en Guyane je suite des
exemples que je connais parce qu'il y en
a sûrement beaucoup d'autres que que je
ne connais pas
euh nous avons
à Saint-Laurent du Maroni de très
nombreuses reconnaissances de paternité
frauduleus fait par des Français comment
peut-on lutter contre cela avec la loi
nationale qui n'a pas du tout intégré ce
type de préoccupation et je crois que si
chacun de mes collègues d'outremer ou
qui a l'expérience de l'outremè voulait
citer des exemples on en ferait ce soir
une
liste considérable mais à chaque fois on
va se demander si nous établissons euh
une proposition de loi ou si le
gouvernement devait établir un projet de
loi pour traiter ce type de difficulté
on est très craintif on a peur de mal
faire euh et euh euh voilà je voulais
vous demander d'une part si vous étiez
prêt à
ouvrir le moment venu une réflexion
d'ensemble pour nous aider à à défaut
vous vous serez certainement ouvert à un
travail avec nous si nous déposions une
proposition de loi après avoir travaillé
pendant madame la Présidente vous nous
direz combien de temps vous nous donnez
mais enfin certainement de nombreux mois
sur un
inventaire à la prèverre de propositions
très diverses procédures
pénal éducation nationale
euh
droit civil il y a beaucoup de domaines
pour lesquels des adaptations seraient
nécessaires il faudrait que ça rentre
dans les adaptations de l'article
73 sinon nous réfléchissons par ailleurs
évidemment à des évolutions
constitutionnelles mais nous savons
combien c'est difficile de les faire
aboutir alors c'est c'est c'est à peine
une question c'est une remarque pour
ouvrir un dialogue avec vous sur la base
de ces considérations dont certaines
évidemment sont assez concrète voire
basique merci chers collègu chers
collègues monsieur le ministre
Victor merci madame la présidente madame
la Présidente Mesdames madame et
monsieur le rapporteur euh j'allais dire
que j'ai lu cursivement le rapport que
vous avez commis euh ou j'ai fait
l'effort bien regarder de bien lire
enfin pas tout mais j'ai bien compris le
sens des propositions que vous faites et
de l'engagement pris euh par le Conseil
d'État notamment sur les études d'impact
et les évaluations dites préalable
euh moi j'ai une question puisque vous
avez placé vos propositions sous un
triptique euh proximité pragmatisme et
et confiance
euh comment être proche quand on est
éloigné je dis ça c'est même pas une
boutade au-delà de du statut de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie c'est 22000 km
Aliss Futuna c'est tout autant la
Polynésie être 20000 km chez moi c'est à
peu près 7000 7500 km bon comment
décliner de manière décentralisée
déconcentrée voire différencier une
politique publique unique et qui se
voudrait
uniforme comment le faire sans pour
autant mettre en cause l'unité de la
norme comment le faire aujourd'hui euh
et et ça on a souvent quelques quelques
souci euh au point que si on va un peu
plus loin dans
l'analyse moi j'ai été ministre Philippe
balité vous prenez une politique et vous
discutez de la façon de la décliner de
l'exécuter vous confiez ça à un ministre
un ministère
euh la première chose déjà pour le 1emer
kilomètre c'est déjà d'intégrer les
autres
m dans la conception noublie les autres
mèes et euh vous avez des études
d'impact les autreses ne figurent pas et
très souvent les études d'impact
elles-mêmes sont
des commentair un peu
légers soumis à la sagacité des
parlementaires
et dans cette affaire là lorsque l'État
se rend
compte je pense pas que c'est fait aussi
délibérément que on n'a pas
pensé laffire pour les autres m on vous
dit on va faire par
ordonnance ou alors des distinctions
parfois un peu spécieuses entre le
législatif et le
réglementaire bref le premier et le
dernier kilomètre c'est les bureau
centraux qui le font c'est les
administrations centrales avec une
exécution déléguée au préfet et au
servicees déconcentrés de
l'État et et donc là on a le problème du
premier et du dernier kilomètre comment
à votre avis après avoir étudié ça et ce
que je vais vous dire pardonnez-moi
c'est pas une critique j'ai cru
comprendre que c'était très inspiré si
je dire du management des organisations
privé de la théorie des organisations et
et et comment l'appliquer dans un
management public
et comment faire en sorte que tous les
acteurs toutes les parties prenantes
soient bien là pour que l'État remplisse
sa mission que on soit le plus proche
possible de l'usager d' dirait du client
final euh comment envisager pour les
autres mires ça quand c'est pensé ici
décliner là-bas avec des corps
intermédiaires des acteurs
intermédiaires et souvent on a du mal à
voir l'usager terminal
finale ultime comment envisager comme
vous le dites à cadre constant puisque
c'est vous dites c'est vrai c'est pas
votre travail
ni vos compétences de d'imaginer un
cadre nouveau comment en cadre constant
à statut constant organisation
administrative
constante intégrer mieux les ares les
décliner sans pour autant remettre en
cause l'unicité de la
norme
madame la Présidente je commence
peut-être à à répondre alors déjà au
sénateur bas je vais être extrêmement
prudente puisqu'il m'a dit
envisagez-vous une étude bon cela ne
relève pas de ma compétence parce que
nous faisons des comme ça je vais
expliquer un petit peu comment on
choisit les thèmes d'études annuel vous
savez on nous réalisons deux séries
d'études des études que nous disons
annuelles et dont nous choisissons le
thème c'est le cas pour le dernier
kilomètre et puis des études qui nous
sont commandées par le Premier ministre
et dans le cadre de l'étude
annuelle le les trois personnes qui sont
là
font des réflexions et proposent à la
section d'abord du rapport et des études
une dizaine de sujets la section du
rapport et des études on sélectionne
quatre ou cinq les parfois les
hiérarchies et c'est ensuite le bureau
du Conseil d'État donc le vice-président
et l'ensemble des présidents de section
le secrétaire général qui choisissent le
thème sur la proposition qu'on leur a
faite donc je ne peux pas président
m'engager car je ne suis pas la personne
compétente pour le faire je dirais
simplement que vous avez ouvert une
autre voix et là j'aurai la même
prudence mais une voix qui vous l'avez
dit et je me souviens très bien du
travail que nous avions mené sur
ensemble parce que c'est bien not
travail qu'on fait ensemble avec le
rapporteur et la section compétente et
ensuite en assemblée générale le travail
qui avait été mené sur la proposition de
loi concernant le le code de la
nationalité son évolution à Mayotte et
il est vrai que cette formule de la euh
de la présentation je veux dire d'une
d'une proposition de loi au Conseil
d'État que permet donc la la
Constitution depuis 2008 est une formule
très précieuse je crois est très utile
et qu'il est pour tous donc je me
bornerai à cela et j'espère que le
sénateur bas m'excusera de de cette
prudence
alors Monsieur le Ministre Victorin
Lurel pour répondre d'une façon un petit
peu global à ce que vous avez évoqué aux
questions que vous avez posé et puis
Mélanie et Fabien complèteront s'il le
faut parce que je ne tiens pas à faire
espèce de one woman show là on est là on
est là à tris et donc nous parlerons à 3
hein comme le travail se fait ainsi avec
la section vous avez évoqué la notion de
proximité et tout de suite vous avez
parlé de la distance
géographique vous avez raison bien
entendu monsieur le sénateur mais pour
nous la
distance nous avons constaté et ça qu'un
fossé s'était creusé nous semblait-il
entre les usagers au sens générique du
terme et les acteurs publics parce que
les usagers avaient le sentiment que
l'action publique nétait peut-être plus
aussi efficace
n'arriz pas véritablement jusqu'à eux
alors un fossé c'est de la distance il
est certain que c'est de la distance
géographique et là les outoutremèes
remportent si je dire tous les records
mais c'est aussi une distance parfois de
la
compréhension parce que vous avez un
discours des formulaires qui sont très
complexes que vous avez trop de normes
aussi ça c'est quelque chose qui est
revenu de nos auditions c'est quelque
chose aussi c'est un sillon que nous
creusons que nous creusons depuis
plusieurs années enfin depuis 30 ans que
nous creusons avec d'autres délégations
sénatoriales avec lesquelles d'ailleurs
nous avons travaillé là-dessus et puis
ou plutôt qui nous ont auditionné sur le
sujet et puis il y a une distance
également en terme même parfois de
comment dirais-je de
considération c'està-dire que ce qui
nous est revenu c'est que parfois on
concerta mais donn l'impression de
concerter mais en réalité tout était
déjà décidé donc cela crée de la
distance en quelque sorte psychologique
là bon alors comment remédier à tout
cela nous faisons donc des propositions
sur la proximité et nous disons sur le
pragmatisme et nous disons vous avez
raison et vous l'avez parfaitement
exprimé monsieur le sénateur mais qu'il
faut penser ce dernier kilomètre dès le
premier donc il faut penser outreem dès
le début
alors la direction générale aux autres
mè a mis en place des outils il y a un
guichet qui est normalement un réflexe
pour les autres administration centrale
mais ce qu'on constate c'est que parfois
quand même ce réflexe il n'est pas
immédiat et qu'il est un peu tardif donc
il faut penser pardonnez-moi le terme
mais atterrissage autre mer comme
atterrissage partout mais atterrissage
are merè dès le
début comment faire alors vous avez dit
vous vous êtes inspiré du secteur privé
alors
euh je j'ai quelques nuances par rapport
à cette expression parce que si nous
avons dit que l'expression du dernier
kilomètre est issue de la logistique
effectivement du secteur privé nous
avons expliqué aussi quand même que elle
s'est développée à propos des villes de
la logistique urbaine mais aussi à
propos de l'aide au développement et là
nous nous l'appliquons vraiment à
l'action publique et ce que nous mettons
en avant c'est du bon sens ce n'est pas
nous prenons quelques distance Parme par
rapport par exemple à ce que l'on
appelle un Espa Mélan en bon français le
New public management bon ce que nous
disons simplement c'est que quand on
pense quelque chose qui doit être au
service de nos concitoyens il faut le
penser avec les acteurs qui sont sur le
terrain donc avec les préfets avec les
association c'est très important avec
les corps intermédiaires si on le peut
avec les usagers eux-mêmes mais c'est
parfois difficile parce que les usagers
parfois ils sont tellement loin qu'on
arrive pas à les saisir mais il y a des
gens qui peuvent parler pour eux et donc
c'est comme ça que l'on peut faire et à
mon avis cela vaut véritablement pour le
l'outrem comme pour la métropole la
méthode doit pouvoir marcher et mettre
en œuvre les mêmes relais les mêmes
relais privilégiés comme nous les
appelons et la dernière chose que je
diraiis à propos de la norme c'est que
vous le savez bien bien nous avons après
notre notre étude sur les
expérimentations quand même il y a eu un
certain nombre de lois don une loi
organique qui va assez loin dans les
expérimentations dans la
diversification à l'occasion don la
différenciation pardon plutôt à
l'occasion de ces expérimentations et
donc nous considérons qu'il y a un
équilibre à tenir il y a d'ailleurs dans
l'étude une analyse qui a été faite par
notre centre de recherche et diffusion
juridique sur l'articulation entre le
principe d'égalité et les nécessités de
la différenciation donc des choses sont
possibles elles seront peut-être
d'autant plus
possibles que l'on n'écrira pas tout
dans les normes ce que nous avons déjà
dit qu'on laissera un peu de marge de
manœuvre qu'on laissera la possibilité
de vous l'avez dit monsieur le sénateur
je crois de prendre son risque qu'on
permettra des adaptations sur le terrain
cette fois-ci et y compris sur le
terrain des outresemes voilà ce que je
peux vous dire je ne sais pas si Mélanie
ou Fabien Fabien va compléter j'espère
avoir commencer à répondre à à vos deux
questions monieur les rapporteur non je
je je me permettrai pas de compléter
mais mais juste peut-être d'apporter
deux enfin de souligner deux points
euh sur euh euh comment faire en sorte
que on pense dès le départ à comment la
réforme atterrit comme l'a dit la
Présidente il nous semble que un point
qui est très important c'est que dans
les études d'impact qui sont on le sait
très inégales certaines sont euh bien
faites d'autres bon voilà passons euh il
nous semble que euh ce qui serait très
important c'est de développer un volet
euh pratique faisabilité pratique
concrètement comment ça va marcher quel
guichet quelle administration va être en
charge et ça permettrait de euh
d'essayer de me mesurer finalement dès
le 1ier kilomètre comment le dispositif
qu'on met en place va fonctionner
effectivement et euh ça serait d'autant
plus important me semble-t-il s'agissant
de l'outreemè ça permettrait aussi de se
rendre compte des cas dans lesquels on
n' pas pensé à à l'application outreem
en tout cas pas suffisamment tôt et où
on improvise ensuite une application qui
n'a pas été réfléchie donc ça je je
trouve que c'est un outil qui est assez
modeste mais mais qui pourrait être
important et la deuxième chose moi qui
me enfin ce qui nous a frappé dans les
les les auditions que nous avons faites
c'est que de même monsieur le sénateur
que vous avez dit qu'il y avait
peut-être plus de marge avec l'article
73 de la Constitution que ce qu'on
imaginait ce qui nous a frappé c'est que
les pouvoirs de dérogation qui ont été
donnés au préfet notamment par le décret
de
2020 sont utilisés avec beaucoup de
prudence et voir une certaine réticence
enfin en tout cas euh bon et pour des
raisons qui peuvent être compréhensibles
la crainte du
contentieux la crainte de ne pas être
suivi par l'administration centrale la
difficulté aussi politique que
soulignait le le sénateur Lurel qui est
quel est le le l'équilibre que l'on fait
entre la différenciation et le principe
d'égalité donc c'est c'est des questions
qui sont qui sont difficiles mais ce qui
ce qui nous a frappé c'est de voir à
quel point il y avait une grande
finalement frilosité peut-être ou en
tout cas prudence pour utiliser les les
dispositifs de différenciation et
finalement c'est un peu la même chose
avec la problématique de l'article 73
donc peut-être aussi que à droit
constant enfin à cadre constitutionnel
constant plus exactement il y a il y a
peut-être plus de marge euh que nous le
pensons et et et peut-être que là il y a
il y a un effort à réaliser et et à cet
égard l'outrem peut être euh en pointe
j'allais dire parce que si s'il y a bien
un domaine dans lequel il y a des marges
euh qui existent grâce à l'article 73 et
où il y a des besoins de différenciation
comp tenu de de de la des différences de
situations qui peuvent exister c'est
bien l'outrem donc voilà c'était les les
deux points que je voulais je me rends
compte si vous permettez madame la
Présidente un mot simplement sur
l'évaluation parce que ce qu'a tout à
fait dit
pertinemment présidentin de la section
du rapport et des études en insistant
sur cet aspect faisabilité des études
d'impact c'est que si vous avez dans des
impact des éléments des indicateurs des
choses très concrètes après vous pouvez
évaluer et vous savez que nous
considérons que c'est quelque chose de
fondamental l'évaluation pas seulement
quand on fait des expérimentations mais
il faut essayer d'évaluer les politiques
publiques pour initinérer les ajuster ou
au contraire ensuite les poursuivre ou
pas donc il y a tout un ensemble de
choses qui doivent permettre justement
d'avoir une politique publique une
action publique plus efficace
Mélanie et peut-être un dernier prier
élément de constat qu'on fait c'est
qu'au fond tout ce qu'on décrit la
présidente de boisfre et le président
Renault nécessite du temps et et
finalement prendre en compte la
spécificité des territoires des
territoires de manière générale mais des
territoires ultraamarin en particulier
nécessite de prendre le temps de
l'écoute de prendre le temps du contact
avec les acteurs de terrain
d'aller-retour et ce
temps-là souvent est un temps un peu
concentré et en réalité quand ça arrive
chez nous au niveau du Conseil d'État en
section
consultative on se rend compte qu'au
fond le temps était tellement concentré
avant que finalement on a un peu gâché
la capacité à bien préparer les choses
et et donc un des nos messages clés et
d'ailleurs c'est la conclusion de de
l'étude c'est que pour bien prendre en
compte le premier le dernier kilomètre
il faut prendre le temps
euh de considérer finalement la
construction de l'action publique et et
ça c'est peut-être le un point qui est
compliqué à à maîtriser
entièrement merci euh je vais laisser la
parole à des collègues si certains
souhaitent s'exprimer donc
euh chers
collègues merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente c'est très intéressant le
rapport de Madame mais j'ai quelques
remarques à faire je sais pas si madame
vous avez pris euh connaissance du
rapport de la chambre rale de comptes de
juin 2022 sur
Mayot si vous avez pris connaissance
tout est làdans tout est dit là-dedans
mais ce qui se passe ce que je voulais
dire c'est que il n'y a pas un seul
autreou il y a des autr m et qu'on ne
peut pas mettre en place une seule
politique des autr m et la deuxème
question
c'est aujourd'hui avec les réseaux
sociaux comment faire de la poli
politique
publique avec bien sûr les réseaux
sociaux nous à Mayotte avant on savait
pas ce qui s'est passé ici à
métropole on nait pas de télé on nait
pas de réseaux sociaux mais aujourd'hui
tout ce qui se passe ici on le voit
immédiatement chez nous et donc on
compare on dit mais comment se fait-il
que nous sommes
français et que on n' pas ça alors que
eux là-bas ils ont tout comment se
fait-il que nous sommes français et
qu'on a la rotation les rotations
scolaires on va à l'école que le matin
et que l'après-midi
euh on va pas à l'école et que je lu dis
à chaque fois l'égalité de Chan euh
elle est où donc évidemment euh nous on
n' même pas commencé le premier
kilomètre on cherche le le sentier pour
arriver sur la route pour faire la le
premier kilomètre et le dernier
kilomètre nous avons aujourd'hui des
violence incroyable à Mayotte là on a
dépassé les boinnes avanthier la
premierre ministre vient à Mayotte
elle prend l'avion le soir et le
lendemain pour la première fois dans
notre histoire il y a eu un jeune qui a
été flingué sur la
route évidemment comme vous l'avez dit
les gendarmes sont envoyés mais comme
c'est pas comme ici ici le maintien de
l'ordre rien à voir avec ce qui se passe
chez nous qu'est-ce qu'ils font et ben
ils nous envoi de grenades lacrymogène
pour disperser les
jeunes sauf que les grenades laacmogène
qui sont envoyé avec nos modes d'habitat
c'est pas les jeunes qui sont embêtés
c'est toute la population aux alentours
qui est embêé et qui se disent écoutez
au lieu de faire disparaître les jeunes
et ben c'est nous les la population qui
sont gêné donc vous voyez moi je pense
que chaque outrouire doit être vu
différemment et plus particulièrement à
Mayotte où nous avons aujourd'hui
contrairement aux autres où la
population diminue nous nous avons un
taux de croissance de 4 % par an avec la
première maternité je dirais du
monde effectivement monsieur le chers
collègues vous avez parlé de la loi euh
sur a modifié sur
euh la nationalité mais cette loi était
destinée justement pour faire en sorte
qu'on baisse la population moi je
demande à ce qu'on fasse des évaluations
des politiques publiques on a eu
plusieurs plans à Mayot Mayot 2025 le
plan de relance le plan machin on a
l'impression que les choses deviennent
de plus en plus difficiles donc il
faudrait peut-être arriver à un moment
donné on fasse une petite pause et se
dire écoutez qu'est-ce qui a marché
qu'est-ce qui n'a n pas marché et
pourquoi ça n'a pas marché euh faire les
je dirais l'inventaire de ce qui n'a pas
marché madame la Première ministre est
venue et nous dit on va reconduire
l'opération chikanda c'est-à-dire la
lutte contre l'immigration clandestine
mais on n'a pas fait de bilan euh
certaines demandent à ce qu'on reconduit
l'opération wombouchou euh où il y a eu
euh tellement de des gens qui sont venus
là-bas des
gendarmes on n'a pas fait de bilan
et on a l'impression que c'est parce
qu'on a fait cette opération que les
choses sont devenu encore plus
difficiles les jeunes non plus peur à
15h ils sont dans la rue avec leur
machett et ils s'entretuent entre eux
donc je pense que chaque
outr doit être pensé différemment parce
que on n pas les même je dirais réalité
que dans
l'Hexagone
merci chers collègu
Jean-Gérard voulait s'exprimer oui merci
madame la Présidente oui j'ai beaucoup
apprécié beaucoup appris de votre exposé
madame mesdames et monsieurs mais je
dirais j'ai beaucoup apprécié aussi le
triptique proximité pragmatisme et
confiance mais je crois que l'usager du
prier au dernier kilomètre n'est pas une
spécificité des autr m et si j'osais je
dirais une impertinence je pourrais moi
les hexagonal vous parler des des outr
teres parce que dans notre hexagone il
n'y a plus d'accueil en préfecture il
n'y a plus aucun accueil en
sous-préfecture les préfets sont très
affaiblis je ne parle même pas des
sous-préfets parce que pendant le covid
préfet au Carole ça dépendait de la RS
quand il y a un problème scolaire ça
dépend du recteur quand il y a un
problème culture ça dépend du Drac donc
on a des des des représentants de l'État
ù je dirais personnellement je je fais
partie de ceux qui qui plaident pour une
concentration accrue parce que je pense
que c'était un un bon équilibre local
par rapport aux collectivités vous avez
souligné mon sujet positif je dirais les
maisons Fran service c'est tout à fait
vrai mais les collectivités ont une part
majeure et sans l'apport des
collectivité je dirais par dans certains
cas j'oseraiis dire que l'État il a posé
le panneau de
communication et enfin je pense que
c'est ressenti je pas je connais pas du
tout les questions d'outre mère d'où ma
venue dans cette délégation mais je
dirais comme un état trop vertical si on
prend par exemple les questions chez
nous duusan qui fait qui fait débat de
la loi Gapi de la question des déchets
et d'une perception d'une action de
l'État comme un état senseur plus que
facilitateur et je pense que la plupart
des des collègues des territoires
attendent de l'état non pas de dire ce
qu'il ne faut pas faire mais d'aider à
savoir comment le faire merci de votre
attention merci je vais laisser la
parole
vivitigal et puis après
à euh oui ça marche merci merci beaucoup
madame mesdames et monsieurs de de votre
exposé et puis de votre présence aussi
ici moi je vous j'avais une question sur
on parle beaucoup ici de de
territorialisation de différenciation au
autres dans la délégation aux AR mè
depuis depuis longtemps et et je crois
que c'est une question cette la
différenciation la territorialisation
on l'a vu avec d'exemple de Mayotte elle
se elle est particulièrement prégante
elle est prégante en en dans l'Hexagone
mais elle est préignante aussi en outrem
tous nos territoires sont différents
mais les peut-être que les outremers les
territoires d'autre mè sont encore plus
différents et là-dedans donc ça
nécessite ce qu'on appelle moi ce que
j'ai envie d'appeler des des des
politiques ascendante c'est-à-dire que
les on a besoin de politique qui
s'adapte au besoins des territoires et
puis qui soit après évalué pour voir si
ces politiques ça aussi au Sénat
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
c'est un de nos dadas je dirais de
nos surquel nous tenons beaucoup et qui
est de moins à moins fait c'est-à-dire
on met en place des dispositifs on les
on les élimine avant de les avoir
évalués et afin de voir ce qu'elles ont
fait ils ont fait sur le terrain c'est
pour ça que je moi je vous avais une
question sur ce que vous pensez des des
appels à projet parce que les appels à
projet c'est vraiment moi j'ai fait un
rapport sur différentes choses où il y
avait beaucoup d'appels à projet ces
appels à projet c'est quelque chose qui
est d'abord c'est une politique
descendante où les territoires qui va
sur des qui va sur des projets dont les
territoires n'ont pas forcément besoin
mais s'ils veulent avoir un peu d'argent
il faut absolument qu'ils y répondent
mais ils mettent du temps très souvent
ces appels à projet et on a l'impression
de plus en plus que les politiques
publiques fonctionnent avec des appels à
projet et donc donc il ne répondent pas
aux besoins des territoires donc moi je
voulais savoir ce que vous en pensiez et
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire pour que
tous nos territoires mais
particulièrement les les territoires
d'outrem ne c'est ça va à l'encontre
d'uneonstruction des politiques or on a
besoin sur C les territoires d'outr
particulièrement qu'on coconstruise les
politiques publiques je crois que
victorien l'a dit aussi qu'il y ait une
coconstruction des politiques public et
des services publics avec les
territoires merci merci je vais Laer la
parole à notre collègue Acli oui alors
moi je j'allais effectivement aller dans
dans sens mais c'est c'est déjà fait
mais ça va me permettre aussi alors de
de préciser et comme on l'a dit c'est
vrai que le problème si vous êtes du
premier au dernier kilomètre le problème
qui se pose c'est vous l'avez souvé
c'est peut-être la préparation du 1emier
kilomètre je pense qu'on est dans
l'impréparation et qu'on est en plus
avec des des schémas descendants
conscendants parfois souvent notamment
par rapport aux outr mè et moi je me dis
qu'on est dans une nouvelle phase de
décentralisation les territoires
d'outrem pourrait être l'espace
d'expérimentation on parle de de la
métropole toujours verreux mais on
pourrait faire le sens inverse et je
pense que si on pensait différpr on
pourrait peut-être cette nouvelle phase
de saison la rendre plus pertinente plus
efficace parce que en associant
l'ensemble des gens peut-être que ça
peut être des laboratoires pour nous
faire évoluer nous permettre de répondre
plus précisément sur nos territoires au
niveau de la
métropole merci chers collèguees Solange
Nadine alors je veux pas être longue
juste merci merci madame la Présidente
merci pour votre exposé alors moi juste
vous demander dans le cas de la
Guadeloupe je vous ai dit j'étais
sénatrice de la Guadeloupe on parle de
la Guadeloupe mais la Guadeloupe est un
archipel dans votre étude avez-vous
pensé au dernier kilomètres comme étant
les a du Sud Marie gallante désira de
les saintes parce que l'État déploie ces
mesures sur la Guadeloupe sauf ce qui
est possible aux abîmes à pointinte à
pite n'est pas forcément possible dans
les île donc ça encore il faut en tenir
en compte autre chose vous dites à qu
conr
institutionnel le même 73 on pourrait on
a fait des propositions l'appel de Fort
de France a donné le sium le sium ce
sont des propositions certaines ont été
retenues on va discuter avec le
gouvernement donc il y a des
propositions de fait troisième problème
moi que je vois dans dans ces
territoires parce que on parle de
territoire et de plusieurs territoires
différents ultramarins c'est de vous
dire vous avez des des service
déconcentrés de l'État comme l'ARS
l'ADAL c'est l'État dans
l'état il est impossible de discuter
avec ces gens-là et ce sont des gens
souvent qui viennent de Paris qui ne
maîtrisent pas le territoire et qui vous
impose qu' ne veulent même pas discuter
moi je vais avoir un entretien avec le
directeur général de Laars et je vous
promets que je vais lui dire ce que je
pense ce sera radical maintenant parce
qu'on me balote entre ministère et ceci
j'ai eu mes réponses écrites donc on va
voir qu'est-ce qu'il me dit maintenant
donc faut pas qu'on dise qu'on a pas de
propositions il y a des propositions de
fait on ne veut pas en tenir compte on
veut que ce soit descendant et il y a un
terme qui est revenu qui est qui est à
la mode maintenant c'est la résilience
moi j'ai fini avec ça pour 2024 je ne
suis plus
résiliente merci beaucoup mer merci
Madame mes chers collègues alors ta r
souhaite prendre la parole oui merci
madame la Présidente
merci Madame d'avoir beaucoup cité la
Polynésie française
euh et donc mais je sais qu'il y a eu
aussi beaucoup de contributions
d'apportter euh sans revenir tout sur
tout ce qui a été dit je m'interroge je
voulais avoir un peu votre sentiment sur
cette notion d'adaptation des modes
d'action de l'État justement dans ses
collectivités de l'article 74 de la
Constitution pour avoir été
vice-président aussi de la Polynésie
française donc au sein du gouvernement
ETM l'économie et des finances à
quelques
reprises on se bien souvent dans ce
concept
d'autonomie aussi à une
méconnaissance de l'État lui-même hormis
quelques spécialistes de
l'outrem sur la manière d'aborder nos
collectivités qui sont largement
autonomes on peut avoir dans un dialogue
on va dire que je qualifierai de
mécanique parfois même des
contradictions assez
évidentes qui n'en sont pas à la si la
lecture était simplement mécanique on va
dire de ces lois
organiques je précise ma pensée
lorsqu'on on peut discuter avec le
gouvernement de la République ou avec
son délégué interministériel qui est au
commissaire de compétences qui sont
aujourd'hui confié à la Polynésie
française on peut avoir en fonction de
nos interlocuteurs pour réponse vous
êtes compétent donc à vous maintenant en
gros vous débrouillez-vous et on l'a pu
on a pu l'entendre à plusieurs reprises
comme à d'autres moments et notamment
pendant la crise covid d'autres
réactions qui dis attention la
République c'est nous tous et à un
moment le préfet le haut-comissaire qui
a eu des euh parfois des comportements
préfectoraux euh dans ces territoires
qui sont pourtant très largement
autonomes et je veux faire notamment
mention à la à la compétence santé euh a
pris des décisions au nom euh de la
liberté d'aller et venir qui parfois
empiétait totalement sur les compétences
de la police française et méconnaissaiit
totalement les institutions locales
alors ça s'agit pas de faire le procès
de la période covid qui était
particulièrement éprouvant pour tout le
monde c'est pas ce que je veux dire mais
à un moment on a quand même aussi euh on
va dire à des frottements des
frottements qui n'ont pas été identifiés
alors qui sont certainement très
difficiles à décrire ou ou à écrire dans
des textes organiques euh mais qui
peuvent conduire à à aussi une nouvelle
réflexion sur comment est-ce que l'État
peut mieux accompagner cette autonomie
et ne pas forcément se situer en
opposition à cette autonomie je je
rappelle souvent je j'ai des mots un peu
forts hein qui vont un peu loin mais
parce que bien entendu dans l'exercice
et heureusement on a souvent de au
fonctionnaires de l'État qui qui font
œuvre à la fois de
bienveillance sans sans être
condescendant et et de et de pragmatisme
mais néanmoins aujourd'hui on on se rend
compte qu'il y a quand même un vide
assez fort dans la pratique de l'état de
ces statuts autonomes et qu'en fonction
et qu'on reste assez tributaire de la
manière don ces aufonctionnaires qui
sont en poste peuvent appréhender cette
autonomie et il me semble que si on a
une réflexion sur l'action de l'État
elle doit aussi prendre en compte euh
alors je n'ai pas là parce que je n'ai
pas cette expérience on va dire de
regret sur peut-être une école de
formation spécifique chez les ha
fonctionnaires pour les outres mires ou
pour ceux de l'article 74 je sais qu'il
y en a eu une euh mais combien même
l'autonomie et je le rappelle souvent
lorsque je je peux rencontrer le
gouvernement de la République le 29 juin
en Polynésie française on célèbre
l'autonomie de la Polynésie parfois
c'est vécu à Paris comme une agression
de la République ou en tout cas une
volonté de distinction de la République
alors qu'en Polynésie on fête la
République quand on fête
l'autonomie et et et souvent ça n'est
pas perçu comme tel euh ce qui nous
différencie des indépendantistes qui
veulent se séparer de la France ou en
fonction des évolutions s'associer
ensuite après donc comment est-ce qu'on
pourrait mieux appréhender ce rapport
aussi de l'état et de nos serviteurs de
l'État euh à ses statuts d'autonomie
comment est-ce qu'on pe améliorer
finalement C ce dialogue qui en fonction
de la qualité de nos interlocuteurs n'a
pas lieu ou peut aussi provoquer euh on
va dire des des frictions des des
frottements mécaniques que j'aiévoqué
tout à l'heure
notamment pendant la crise covid je vous
prends un exemple pour être un peu
concret sur le sujet et encore une fois
il s'agit pas de refaire le procès de la
la période covid mais lorsqu'à un moment
pour des raisons de santé publique alors
on a eu parfois quelques désagrébles
surpris de découvrir que lorsqu'on
décrétait un confinement à Paris il a
aussi été appliqué en Polynésie qui
avait un contexte sanitaire totalement
différent mais en disant la République
est une et indivisible et on doit tous
être ensemble au même moment sauf que
sur les questions de santé on peut y
apporter des nuances heureusement ça n'a
pas été le cas toute la période mais
lorsqu'à un moment aussi on dit il faut
par exemple euh vacciner tout le monde
mais la compétence santé fait que c'est
la Polynésie française qui doit payer
les infirmières qui vaccinent
ou qu'on peut dire que pour des raisons
euhh sanitaires il faut mettre en place
un confinement des des voyageurs qui
arrivent en Polynésie française par
contre la Polynésie doit payer l'hôtel
qui accueille les voyageurs parce que ça
n'est pas de la compétence de l'État
voilà je veux pas refaire un procès
covid mais simplement et si je reviens
hors covid sur d'autres questions le
développement de l'riculture la
protection des zones de pêche euh ou le
développement on va dire euh de la pêche
artisanale en poly française et de
compétenence polynésienne mais en a en
moins on a des sujets autour de la
formation maritime et de titres euh des
diplômes qui euh qui relèvent toujours
de l'État et qui amèneent aujourd'hui à
une une carence très forte euh de
capitaine euh pour avoir des Polynésiens
sur les bateaux de pêche qui pêchent en
Polynésie en toute exclusivité voilà et
on sent qu'il y a souvent c'est plus
feutré que ça am a une méconnaissance et
parfois même une une réaction mécanique
dire mais vous êtes compétent finalement
l'État n'a pas grand chose à vous dire
alors si nous reprenons cette idée
républicain nous partageons tous et que
partagent les autonomistes en Polynésie
française il s'agit peut-être de se
mettre d'accord sur l'essentiel et de
voir comment on peut y arriver qu'on
soit autonome ou pas il faudrait pas que
l'autonomie soit un frein à la capacité
tous de concevoir ensemble les
politiques publiques et de les mener au
bout voilà pardonnez-moi si j'étais un
peu
long merci chers collègues s'il n'y a
pas d'autres intervention pour terminer
cette salve de question et rejoindre un
peu ce que disaient mes collègues vous
avez fort justement parler de distance
de la compréhension de distance de
considération peutant voilà même si on
on on le
constate affirmer qu'il n'y a pas de
culture outremère dans les
administration c'est un des un point
nodal comment aussi repenser la relation
entre l'État et ses territoires on a
parlé aussi d'évolution institutionnelle
mais de de révision constitutionnelle
des statuts à la carte puisque le notre
collègue Saïd a parlé des outremes des
statuts à la carte des statuts surmesure
pourrait-il aussi apporter des solutions
à ces ces problématique de d'efficience
de politiques publiqu dans les
territoires parce que c'est c'est bien
de ça don dont on parle d'une manière
générale juste avant que il ne répondent
pour aller dans ton sens
euh la première chose c'est que pour
répondre à esto je t'appelle comme ça
euh c'est le ministère des outr-emèes
depuis quelques temps on dit ministère
de l'outr-emère c'est vrai qu'il y a des
outrèes différents des aromèes ensuite
sur la prise en en compte euh des
intérêts disons des autres on n' pas
d'intérêt propres au sein de la
République avec l'article 73 c'est autre
chose pour le 64 j'avais trouvé une
astuce quand j'étais ministre euh
j'avais euh fait nommer avec l'accord du
gouvernement des euh conseillers dans
tous les ministères et en amont lorsque
les questions étaient évoquées je le
savais et je réunissis tous les deux
mois tous s conseillés je prends un
exemple pour illustrer ça lorsqu'on
m'avait demandé de faire 180 millions
d'économie euh payon qui était ministre
de l'éducation nationale n'avait pas
hésité à faire à mon u des économies sur
les lycées de pointbout et de Mont d'Or
en Nouvelle-Calédonie je l'ai su parce
que en amont ensuite ça un peu mal fini
parce qu'on disait c'était des espions
dans les cabinet et cetera mais ça
marchait je peux vous dire ça ça
marchait en amont on savait donc ce qui
se préparait et puis c'est poser la
question que vous avez en tête en 2007
il y a une vraie question et qui est
toujours au fond des têtes je ve dire
faut-il le ministère des outresmèes euh
ou alors laisser à l'époque il avait 38
ministère et secrétariat d'État faut-il
euh cette dispersion et ne plus avoir
une unité de coordination que Jacques
Chirac avait appelé un petit Matignon
c'est pas un petit Matignon démuni de
moyens avant il y avait deux directions
générales euh là maintenant il y a il y
avait une délégation générale autre ma
c'est moimême qui l' est transformé en
direction générale autreem il y avait à
l'époque près de 300 personnes là
aujourd'hui à peine 130 personnes
manifestement il y a là un problème de
de de ressources humaines pour vous
montrer les difficultés on vient de
voter une réforme des retraites
euh aujourd'hui on nous dit dans le PLF
qu'on vient de voter là aujourd'hui on
nous dit
euh l'état n'ayant pas suffisamment
pensé les problèmes de retraite des
agriculteurs autre maire nous demandons
au Parlement de nous déléguer ce pouvoir
et nous ferons donc par ordonnance et je
peux vous dire c'est une petite
révolution qui est en train de se faire
moi j'étais directeur de chambre
consulaire je sais ce qui se prépare là
mais l'État ne vous donnera quelques
mois avant septembre
2024 là où on va commencer à analyser en
tant masquer le PLF 2025 on va vous
donner une étude d'impact un peu légère
sur une chose qui est considérable parce
que on n'a pas pensé la choses c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué il faut le dire
si on devait retarder cette réforme
structurelle faite même si j'étais moi
en désaccord et qu'il fallait attendre
qu'on soit prêt autre ma on a une
difficulté fondamentale areè c'est qu'il
y a pas d'étude préalable l'INC par
exemple l'in vous n'avez pas les armes
de politique économiqu les armes de
décision et c'est la raison pour
laquelle souvent on a du retard et on le
fait au pif au MRE et au radar très
souvent voilà je m'arrête merci chers
collègu
je nous n'allons pas être trop de tro
pour répondre à toutes ces questions
tout à fait
intéressantes je vais me permettre quand
même déjà une précaution c'est que je
trouve que certaines question était
plutôt sur un champ politique si je veux
dire au au très bon sens du terme et
donc là je considère que nous sortons du
champ de l'étude je vous ai dit nous
nous sommes là pour parler de l'étude
donc je m'abstiendrai de de réagir
là-dessus dans l'ordre et donc le
président Renault et Madame la
rapporteur générale adjointe Mélanie V n
complèterons pour vous répondre monsieur
le sénateur nous parlons bien
d'outreemère au pluriel dans l'étude et
je crois l'avoir dit également oralement
et c'est vrai qu'il n'y a pas un
outreemère il y a des outremèes et des
situations fort différente
et nous en avons conscience je crois et
nous l'avons exprimé en utilisant le le
pluriel
ensuite vous avez monsieur le sénateur
d'indrloir insistit en disant mais
finalement le problème n'est pas
seulement celui des outrem c'est aussi
celui de l'outre terre je crois que nous
l'avons écrit et c'est vrai que nous
nous sommes intéressés nous avons écouté
des élus venant de territoires très
divers je ne suis pas rentré dans le
détail mais des territoires urbains pé
urbains ruraux ultramarins et qu'il y a
des difficultés des égalité là aussi
selon selon les endroits ce que vous
avez dit sur la maison France service
nous en sommes bien consciion aussi hein
la part des des collectivités
territoriales il n'empêche que nous
considérons que c'est quelque chose qui
est important et qui est positif dans le
contexte d'aujourd'hui et partout
notamment et je dirais partout mais pas
seulement dans les territoires ruraux et
dans les territoires ultramarins mais
aussi dans certains territoires urbains
il faut l'avoir en tête alors enite ite
il y a eu différents éléments qui
tournaient autour de la
coconstruction sur le fait à la fois
sous un angle critique l'État et senseur
plutôt que
facilitateur sous l'aspect finalement
des schémas descendants alors qu'il
faudrait et même condescendant j'ai
trouvé la formule frappante alors qu'il
faudrait de
l'ascendant tout cela je ne peux
qu'adhérer car c'est ce que nous avons
écrit et nous avons beaucoup insisté sur
le fait que l'on ne pouvait pas faire
seul que les
administrations centrales doivent
écouter déjà leurs représentants sur le
terrain elles doivent écouter les élus
elles doivent écouter les associations
qui sont si importantes elles doivent si
elles le peuvent et dans certains cas
étudier et pardon écouter les les
usagers et vous l'avez bien dit madame
la sénatrice de Guadeloupe parce que le
dernier kilomètre c'est pas seulement
pointapitre ou baser mais ça peut être
des plus au sud alors les saintes sont
un peu moins au sud j'ai eu la chance
d'aller quand j'étais enfant et donc je
garde un souvenir absolument ébloui bon
donc il y a nécessité effectivement de
cette construction de cette prise en
compte de tous et c'est ça comme le
rappelait Mélanie viler qui va prendre
du temps mais qui aussi appelle une
certaine culture c'est pour ça que nous
disons que nos notre triptique proximité
pragmatisme et confiance par ce trptit
qui semble très modeste il semble de bon
sens mais si on veut vraiment le
généraliser si on veut faire en sorte
que les bonnes pratiques parce que ça
existe je veux être moins quand même
optimiste les bonnes pratiques les les
propositions que nous avons faites
ellees reposent sur des choses que nous
avons vu ou entendu qui existe et bien
ce qu'il faut c'est qu'elle change comme
nous l'avons dit de braquer c'est une
métaphore sportive he pour ceux qui
aiment le vélo mais on doit changer de
braquer ben ça ça devient beaucoup plus
ambitieux parce qu'il faut ut qu' y a
une autre culture qui se mette en place
et pour que cette culture se mette en
place celle que vous appeliez de vos
vœux monsieur le sénateur de de
polyinésie monsieur le sénateur
également de sa Saint-Denis et bien il
faut peut-être aussi qu'on forme les
acteurs de l'État qu'on les forme un peu
partout à cela et qu'il y ait une
culture de l'outrem
partout monsieur le sénateur Lurel l'a
dit il avait des référents moi je crois
que non enfin je ne prends it pas partir
surtout pas sur l'organisation à venir
je vous ai dit que nous ne sommes pas
légitimes à le faire sur organisation de
l'État je dirais simplement sur la base
de mon expérience personnelle qu'il y
a quelques années c'est le le bénéfice
ou désavantage d'un âge qui commence à
être certain il y avait des gens qui ne
connaissait l'outre-emère dans toutes
les administrations ce qui n'empêchait
pas le ministère on disait plutôt
l'outr-emè à l'époque d'ailleurs que des
outremèes d'être utile mais enfin tous
les cas à l'époque he je porte un trait
vous voyez je porte un bon donc il y a
pas de il y a pas d'acontrario entre les
deux mais il y avait une culture il y
avait une
connaissance et donc quand un projet de
loi s'élaboré quand on réfléchissait à
une un dispositif qu'on faisait
interministériellement mais mais le
ministère porteur quand même se posait
la question et après il se posait la
question il avait la réponse ou pas mais
il avait quand quand même il se l'a posé
il avait le réflexe ensuite d'aller voir
quelle était la bonne réponse donc ça
c'est de la culture et c'est aussi son
doute ça passe par la formation je crois
que c'est tout à fait fondamental et par
la connaissance du terrain euh ce que
nous nous disions en aparté c'est que il
nous semble que ce qui manque c'est une
culture territoriale dont celle des
outres mères et puis j'aurais un mot
simplement pour dire mais je demande
vraiment à mes voisins de compléter
parce que je n'ai pas répondu à tout un
mot pour dire que je rejoins
complètement tout ce qui a été dit par
plusieurs d'entre vous mais nous
l'avions déjà je crois mise en avant
c'est cette nécessité
d'évaluer cela malheureusement aussi
peut prendre du temps mais c'est
tellement important parce que là cela
permet de faire des choses en
connaissance de cause et je vais être
paradoxal mais moi je suis d'accord pour
que
des politiques c'est leur liberté totale
même après une évaluation qui serait
mauvaise dise on continue pour tel et
tel raison mais on le fait en
connaissance de cause et on
l'explique on est dans le la
redevabilité finalement de l'action
publique sur laquelle nous insistons
depuis une étude sur la citoyenneté en
2018 où nous proposions déjà que les
citoyens soient associés à l'évaluation
à l'époque cétait expos des politiques
publiques et puis nous avons 2020
continuer sur le sujet d'ailleurs avec
le concours lors d'une conférence qui eu
lieu le 28 février 2020 du président du
Sénat
lui-même merci madame la Présidente si
vous voulez ajouter non je je j'ai pas
grand chose à ajouter ce que je voulais
peut-être juste dire c'est par rapport à
la question sur l'article
euh nous avons fait notre réflexion à
cadre constitutionnel constant comme le
rappel la présidente donc on s'est pas
poser de questions sur faut-il évoluer
ou pas ce qui me semble j'allais dire de
manière encore plus nette je suis pas un
spécialiste du sujet mais c'est que à
plus forte raison évidemment dans le
casadre de l'article 74 les les marches
sont plus grandes que évidemment dans le
cadre de l'article 73 et j'ai
l'impression que en réalité la
difficulté que vous pointez du doigt
c'est c'est ça c'est la question de la
mise en pratique du pragmatisme et de la
confiance voilà il y a il y a un
problème en réalité de confiance
et je crois que c'est c'est en ça qu'il
faut que on arrive à élaborer ensemble
des politiques qui soient coconstru
prévisible durable parce que il y a
aussi cette question de la durabilité et
donc voilà c'est pour ça que il nous
semble que la clé elle est plutôt de ce
côté-là que du côté simplement de
l'obstacle juridique du du texte article
74 pour compléter d'un mot sur sur ce
sujet oui allez-y madame s'il vous plaît
est-ce que vous avez rencontré des élus
et des habitants de parcs naturels
régionaux parce que quand je vous
entends moi je fais partie d'un parc
naturel où j'ai siégé pendant plus de 30
ans c'est tout à fait ça on que
pardon c'est cette logique et vraiment
moi j'ai l'impression que les parcs
aussi bien en métropole que dans en
outrem on est des îles comme ça et on se
on se gère c'est des laboratoires
d'idées c'est les habitants qui gèrent
leur territoire et on a une confiance
absolue dans ce qu'on fait donc vraiment
je je trouve que je me retrouve
complètement dans les parcs naturels
merci
excusez-moi je vous en prie madame
Willer alors j'ai pas souvenir qu'on est
spécifiquement auditionné ou ou voilà
rencontrer des acteurs investis dans un
parc naturel régional mais la méthode
est une méthode qui finalement a été
c'est une méthode illustrée dans un
grand nombre d'auditions et peut-être ce
que je peux dire pour illustrer la
confiance une de nos de nos proposition
un peu phare de de l'étude c'est dire
qu'au fond cette confiance elle doit se
traduire par le fait d'associer dans la
construction de la politique publique
ceux qui vont la mettre en œuvre et de
pas être dans cette dichotomie et et
c'est vrai en particulier dans le champ
des compétences
décentralisé où
aujourd'hui les
habitudes administratif font que on on
sollicite les acteurs locaux souvent sur
la base de réformes qui sont déjà
presque ficelé presque arbitré et qu'au
fond finalement le dialogue avec les les
élus alors qu'il soit de territoire
métropolitain ou de territoire
ultramarin ce dialogue il arrive presque
en fin de course là où tout est déjà
presque calé et au fond notre message et
ce ce sur quoi on a insisté dans l'étude
c'est de dire cette méthode dans un
univers qui assume la décentralisation
euh elle doit d'abord commencer par
construire des agendas communs et on
donne cette illustration sur deux
politiques publiques qui nous semblent
majeures dans les années à venir la
transition écologique qui se fera pas
sans les acteurs locaux et le
vieillissement qui l' aussi compenu de
l'éclatement des compétences et cetera
ne se fera pas sans les acteurs locaux
en métropole et en
outreemè et donc ça ça c'est presque une
petite révolution finalement de réussir
à construire des agendas communs et de
pas mener le dialogue uniquement quand
tout est
ficelé madame la Présidente je n'ai pas
répondu à madame la sénatrice sur les
appels à
projet alors nous avons des
développements sur les appels à projets
qui ne sont pas très
positifs donc nous nous retrouvons dans
ce que vous avez dit et il nous a été
indiqué notamment par des représentants
d' association que les Appells à projet
alors qu'on élabore à tous les niveaux
mais enfin ils sont souvent quand même
élaborés au niveau national sont tenir
compte déjà des spécificités local mais
ensuite on les utilise à tous les
niveaux et on met les gens en
concurrence alors que souvent il
vaudrait mieux que des associations se
mettent ensemble parce que ce sont des
acteurs hein les associations très
souvent aussi du dernier kilomètre he
parler du vieillissement notamment dans
le cadre de l'aide au personnes âgées de
l'aide à domicile et bien il vaudrait
mieux utiliser d'autres choses d'autres
voies nous nous disons par exemple
l'appel à manifestation d'intérêt que
ces appels à projet qui partaiit de nous
le savons bien euh d'une intention tout
à fait louable il s'agissait de
rationaliser un peu ce que l'on faisait
pour répondre à des dérives ou à des
critiques mais je dois dire que la
plupart des personnes que nous avons
auditionné se sont montrés très
sceptiques vis-à-vis des appels à projet
que nous en avons rendu compte de cette
manière voilà j'avais oublié cela et
tous les trois nous disions ah les
appels à projet donc je je voulais quand
même en parler
voilà merci merci
vraiment non non mais c'est intéressant
parce que notre collèguefriit a posé une
question et j'aimerais juste revenir un
peu puisque le président Fabien c'est
bien ça votre nom nom Renault Fabien
Renault c'est votre prénom c'est votre
prénom répond que vous avez jugé à cadre
constant on a compris ça il pose une
autre question euh je crois comprendre
ça que il y a déjà une conception de
l'autonomie qui est différente ici et
là-bas vous avez une conception qui est
française et qui était meilleure à
l'époque l'anglaise vous prenez ou vous
demandez à assurer en autonomie telle ou
telle
politique l'Angleterre vous lâche
totalement vous vous débrouillez la
France éétait pas ça même si il y a des
dotations moindres moindre et lorsqu'il
y a urgence il y a
nécessité l'État se substitue on l'a vu
dans la gestion du covid en en en
Polynésie euh l'état empiète et l'État
ne finance pas toujours sauf dans
l'affaire du covid où c'est vrai euh la
l'État s'est substitué lorsqu'on a cette
conception de l'autonomie qui est qui
consiste à dire l'égalité pour moi
transcendre les
statuts égalité c'est la devise de la
République mais si vous prenez euh un
statut d'autonomie vous avez moins
d'argent pour être clair et un peu
trivial vous avez moins d'argent et
l'État interprète cette conception de
l'autonomie à sa manière comment
réfléchir au premier et au dernier
kilomètre si déjà au départ la
conception n'est pas la même sur le
périmètre de l'autonomie c'est on a ce
problème là et d'ailleurs je peux vous
dire c'est un frein pour l'évolution
institutionnelle ou l'évolution
statutaire chez nous en disant ah ouais
l'autonomie non laissez ça pour la
Polynésie il y a plus d'argent non on n
veut pas bon voilà donc c'est pour que
que que je lise autrement votre rapport
pour voir si je peux tirer des choses
très je dirais je je n'entrerai pas dans
sur un terrain qui pourra être politique
je dirais
simplement que je crois qu'il faut à ce
moment-là commencer par partager des
constats porter des diagnostics
communs unifier son langage il faut
quand même que l'on parle de la même
chose et donc ça c'est le début de la
coconstruction alors Mélanie vilé à
parler des agendas partagés moi je
dirais déjà aussi des diagnosti partagés
et donc avec des approches qui sont les
mêmes parce que si vous avez des déjà si
vous donnez des ENF si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord sur le diagnostic ça pose un
vrai problème comment pourrez-vous
construire quelque chose ensemble
ensuite donc il faut partager les
diagnostics
ensuite sur cette base
se donner le temps de
s'écouter les uns les autres et
effectivement et je crois qu'on on
serait content de terminer là-dessus et
se faire confiance à tous les niveaux
respectivement et
réciproquement merci Madame la président
merci madame la Présidente je vais clore
l'audition sur C sur ce ces belles
paroles mais j'ai le sentiment et je
pense qu'il est partagé par mes
collègues d'avoir été enfin entendu et
compris parce que c'est difficile et mes
collègues pourront me me le confirmer et
vraiment c'est de bonne augure pour la
suite de ce travail merci à vous madame
la Présidente vous ne pouviez pas nous
faire un meilleur compliment et un plus
beau compliment merci pour votre
attention merci pour vos questions
et vraiment nous nous sommes vous le
voyez je suis même un peu ému d'avoir
entendu cela merci
encore